all time of year man in the winter in
the summer in the spring in the orchard
guess where i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
right here in my hot tub baby
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i wanted to
reveal the kind of thing that i like to
spend my money on
now this channel is not a showy off
channel at all and to be honest i'm not
a show your person i live a reasonably
simple-ish life considering you know how
well my business
has done and is doing and one of the
things that
one of the reasons i wanted to become
successful is because i wanted to be
able to provide a good life for my
family
i wanted to be able to go on holidays i
wanted to travel traveling something
that i really enjoy
and the reason i am happy to spend money
on travel but not clothes i mean geez
this top
i don't know how much this top's worth
very cheap very inexpensive
normally i try not to spend money on
things that are not tax deductible
however i just made a massive purchase a
very big purchase
and the thing that i bought is a hot tub
i'm going to show you the hot tub in a
minute mandy looks ready to go in the
hot tub
are you ready amanda i'm ready she's
ready she's ready so this has come we've
been waiting
months for this to come we're
ridiculously excited
and here's how i could justify because
people you know might be saying samuel
how could you spend so much money on a
hot tub and here's why
manny we spend money on holidays right
yes we spend big when how much money do
we spend on california trip
how much on dubai tens of thousands
expensive
close to 100 i think it's like 61 000
pounds on dubai
which is crazy money but the thing is if
i'm having down
time okay because i don't have lots and
lots of down time
i'm happy i like to spend money on
experiences so this hot tub this is my
justification
my because maddie who's the tight one
out of us too with the money do you
reckon you're probably the tight one
i'm tight so i have to justify it to
amanda my justification was this i said
look
we've had to cancel our holidays this
year because of corona virus
we won't even want to go on expensive
holidays anymore because we've got a
beautiful house
if we've got a nice hot tub you know we
weren't even
going home those so this is it this is
the tub it's turned on
it's uh it's pretty warm how high is
this right now
um i think it's about 36 degrees 86
degrees did you want to go in first and
forth
you can go first we're gonna go in now
disclaimer
i do get a tiny tiny discount off the
hot tub
for featuring it in a youtube video so
i'm going to leave a link in the
description that's my disclaimer okay
i'm not becoming an influencer now i'm a
property guy
and according to liv cook that wasn't
cringy and that's okay don't quote me on
that yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right so let's
get in there also do you wanna pass my
beer
that's my beer alright hold on i'm gonna
jump in you get right in i'll jump in a
second
all right let's do this let's do this
now my phone i'm notorious i'm notorious
for it for my phone going in water
all right
i had a hot tub and they were giving me
a bit of a discount i'd do it
that'd feature it okay oh
yeah okay this is not even a hot tub is
it liv what is this
swimming pool this thing it's like not a
hot tub it's a cross between a swimming
pool and a hot tub
and you can literally okay you want to
swim
you want to swim this
is a swim mill like a treadmill
that's pretty cool right
you can make it stronger as well so if
you turned off these jets
that would be much faster as it'd be
much harder to swim again
here's the thing okay i just feel
so at peace when i'm in water and
to to get a house with a swimming pool
attached onto it
a nice house like this with a swimming
pool will be way more expensive
and i always used to think to amanda or
we should say would you prefer an indoor
pool or an outdoor pool
neither neither we just get a nice
warm swim spa hot tub thing that
massages you and you can kind of like
because when we go swimming
all we tend to do is float anyway you
know we just float around and chat
so uh i love this thank you to christina
christina was the lady that made this
happen right yeah christina's
christine is amazing if you're gonna get
an expensive
hot tub or an expensive anything an
expensive car
expensive clothes as long as you're
paying for it out of your passive income
okay don't buy something that you cannot
afford okay
so as long as your this is completely
paid for
by our passive income so i can justify
it become financially free
so you can do things like live in a nice
house drive a nice car
get a hot tub no big deal but don't do
it if you can't afford it
and get into bad debt see the
interesting thing is banks
okay and companies will let you buy this
you'll even see on the adverts buy now
pay later
no problem it's interesting that you can
buy a hot tub now and pay for it later
but you start saying do that with a
house buy an investment property now and
pay for it later people go oh that
sounds dodgy
oh it's risky whatever's if the
investment goes down it's like what this
is crazy
so invest in nice things spoil yourself
sometimes
but only do it when first you become
financially literate you understand the
difference between good debt and bad
debt
you understand what an asset and a
liability is and you're paying for it
out of your
passive income not your active income
that'd be my advice
that'd be my advice what do you reckon i
agree with you she agrees with me that's
always a good thing that's always a good
thing
so anyway hope you liked the video hope
you like the hot tub
i like the hot tub mandy likes the hot
dog i love the hot tub
she loves the hot tub so subscribe
smash a like and drop a comment i'll see
you next time